people of the internet this is dr john
deloney
today we are talking about controlling
behavior anxiety
relational iq self-importance and
grandiosity
sounds like every man you know and every
dude that i know so here we go
i'm responding to an email that i got at
askjohn ramseysolutions.com
let's get into it good afternoon dr
dolony it's the morning here but i get
what you're saying
and also with you i just found your
independent channel but i've listened to
you
a couple of times as a co-host with dave
ramsey let's be honest i'm carrying dave
on his radio show but it is what it is
i'm a college student with no personal
debt and i plan to remain that way as i
have a full scholarship
rock onto the break of dawn dude my
problem is that i tend to emotionally
take on the debt of people that i care
about
i don't even know what that means let's
continue my girlfriend of four years has
student loans
and i feel kind of guilty because i
don't have any i guess that i also feel
guilt because part of me knows she chose
this school
because i also chose the school so i
feel somewhat responsible for her debt
this manifested into me being
controlling with her money
and attempt to help her manage it well
come on man well i have stopped the
controlling behavior the anxiety about
her debt is still on my mind
constantly even though i know it
shouldn't be because it's not
my debt or my money i guess my question
is how do i deal with this guilt and
emotionally separate myself from other
people's financial situations
abraham thank you so much for the email
thank you for reaching out thank you for
calling out your own dumb behavior and
working hard to fix it
i want you to listen to me carefully
because i'm going to shoot you straight
i'm going to go through this quick
this is especially a challenge for dudes
here's the challenge
we fall in love the deeper we fall in
love
the tighter that relationship gets the
more connected we get
and the more connected in love we get
the more we realize
i can't make somebody else love me i
can't make somebody else
make the decisions that i think are
smart and so the more we
love and the more we get connected and
the more we realize we can't control
somebody else in our life
we start to feel small and when dudes
feel small they respond with grandiosity
we puff our chest out
and then go about solving problems and
so when you say here that your
girlfriend was so in love with you that
she decided to go to the same college as
you even was going to cost her
student loan money and you responded to
that by controlling her money and her
decisions and her behavior
that's a recipe for a bomb to go off in
your heart
and especially in her heart you cannot
base a relationship on control because
when somebody feels controlled
they begin to pull away and the
controller controls tighter
and then you suffocate somebody and the
relationship ends
so abraham and everybody listening
here's a few hard truths
and things you can do right now to not
take on the guilt and responsibility of
other people's challenges
other grown-ups decisions and instead to
be with folks and to love them okay
number one you are a person
of value you have worth
and you are not that important quit
making everybody else's problems
about you quit making everybody else's
financial decisions everybody else's
different opinions everybody else's
choice on what they want to eat for
dinner
about you so number two
the only things on planet earth you can
control
are your thoughts and your actions so
stop the controlling behavior
if a woman loves you so much or she's
going to take out a student loan
and follow you to whatever college you
go to that's her decision
controlling her and her money will only
fracture
your relationship fracture your psyche
and your self-worth
and break down a woman who just loves
you if you have a disagreement
on how someone you love and someone you
want to spend the rest of your life with
is spending their money you sit down and
you have a heart-to-heart conversation
about value
and about what you think is important
and why it affects you the way it does
and you look them in the eye and you say
i love you and here's my heart on this
and then you put a period at the end of
that sentence if she chooses to go get a
student loan
you choose whether you're going to stay
in a relationship with her or not that's
it man
controlling her money trying to weasel
your way into
making her decisions for another person
is gonna crush her
crush you and destroy your relationship
and that leads me to number three
if you have contributed to somebody
else's dumb decision
don't just flex up and muscle through it
solve it through relationship repent
tell you're sorry
tell her you screwed up you wish you
hadn't encouraged her to take on all
this debt
and encourage her to go to the things
that are going to be right for her
and for her financial situation and if
you're gonna get married
get married and then you're gonna make
joint decisions but until you're locked
up
legally and spiritually there's not a
lot you can speak into
and that brings me number four student
loans are stupid don't do it
i've been there they're idiotic so i'm
going to send you a few things
abraham because you had the courage to
write so i'm going to send you a copy of
anthony o'neil's
best-selling book debt free degree and i
want you to sit down with her
look her in the eye and say you are a
grown woman who i love
you are able to make your own decisions
and you're probably a lot smarter than
me
on most every issue in the world here is
a book
written by a great author from a great
company and talks about the dangers of
student loans and what you can do about
it
and then you can give her that book and
she gets to make a grown-up choice for
what to do
moving forward you my friend have to put
the guilt
and the controlling behavior down
i'm also gonna give you a year-long
subscription to the new ramsay plus
and i'm going to encourage you and her
to do that
together it's going to give you some
good tools on how to speak to one
another
how to in a non-controlling way come
together talk about your values
who you want to be and how you're going
to work together moving forward in your
relationship and for you
i want you to get on amazon and buy the
book i don't want to talk about it by
terence real
it's a great book i think you're going
to benefit from it so to wrap up
stop the controlling behavior recognize
that you can only control
two things your thoughts and your
actions and that's
it if you contribute to somebody else's
bad decisions tell them you're sorry ask
for forgiveness
and bring some support to the table
through relationship
not through muscle and bone and steel
and hammer and nails put the controlling
behavior
away this is dr john delony with ramsey
network thanks for joining us
push all the buttons subscribe shoot me
an email at ask john ramseysolutions.com
and i'll talk to you soon stay in school
don't do drugs